[Music]
that should be our theme sign what if we
just changed one let one note it was
like
could we get away with it
would they sue us
or their publicity i don't think it's
worth it you know i think no i think
we'd get away with it because they
wouldn't want to they wouldn't have
illegal bills yeah legal bills but i'm
sure i'm sure they have tons of money
for that
um i just don't know how to pivot into
what we were talking about we were um
going to talk about how we have a big
family dinner coming up and i've been
tasked with tasked
with uh baking cupcakes for our nephews
apparently our nephews have been asking
for lemon cupcakes i have the lemons but
what i don't have is is any idea beyond
that how to bake lemon cupcakes i'm i've
never been much of a baker and
for all the reasons why i love
cooking i don't really like being so
precise and with baking you have to be
precise and so
um i'm going to try it i'm going to give
it a shot so if anyone has any good
lemon cupcake recipes
send them our way we'll give you the
email later
um let's give it now life is short at
wondering.com why not yeah you might not
be around later what you might would not
want to listen to
they might not be yes oh okay wow you'll
be around yes you're breaking precedence
that's not usually your uh you're
feeling frisky yeah this is that this is
a new vibe for you let's get into the
show okay oh wow a beginning vibe
excited to begin vibe i like that
life could be a dream
life could
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
[Music]
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my my brother
you have a brotherly vibe can i offer
some
criticism please write it off the top
yeah why not yeah wow you're really well
but it's mixing it up today it's it's
not just criticism it's it's a
compliment and a critique oh even better
it's uh
what would that be uh
com
competique company yeah um you are i i
think you're an excellent cook oh thanks
really good and like you've gotten a lot
better over the last couple years even
but incredible i think you've yeah you
were listening until your eyes were
floating away
you were um you've become a very very
capable cook i would say oh thanks but i
don't think you're a good baker no and i
and i think the reason is
i'm not it's very simple
and it's just because cooking
with cooking you're allowed to you're
able to yeah improvise
and not be precise not be exact yeah
grow this and throw that in
uh and that kind of
works with you or yeah artistic it feels
more artistic energy yeah but baking
feels like numbers baking is like
science baking is math it's like i want
to be in a lab coat with a beaker you
have to be exact with baking
like a teaspoon and a half yes a baking
powder is a teaspoon and a half of
baking powder and if you don't do it the
whole thing could get [ __ ] up i know i
know especially bread you know bread is
a very specific it's like a science it's
anything cupcakes in this case yeah i
know why are we talking about baking um
well i'll answer myself i can answer for
you why because uh we have a guest on
the show today yeah
a guest who happens to be an excellent
baker in her own right and
an excellent host of an excellent show
called nailed it nailed it well you
nailed that intro nailed it is a
terrific
baking show on netflix it's been on for
years four four years now maybe yeah
it's awesome and she's been nominated
for emmys for it so she's the host of
the show she does
everything she is nicole byer
she has a thousand podcasts one of which
is called why won't you date me uh-huh
she's a great one yeah um but she hosts
so many podcasts
and she hosts so many shows
out with john
yeah uh the the aforementioned nailed it
um and of course uh yes uh she has the
book out the hashtag very fat very brave
a very funny netflix special called
called bbw which stands for
big beautiful weirdo
and we talk about that we talk about the
special and all the stuff she has going
on um i never met her i have i've been
hearing her name you know in the ether i
don't know how she has time to sleep at
night she might be like you know who
who's the guy that doesn't sleep uh i
think a lot of really successful people
have powerful news howard hughes didn't
sleep but uh did he
figure i
whose name now is uh steve diddy
his what's diddy's name now uh did he or
didn't he change it to is it just love i
think i love love i think so too he's
love so love
love i've always thought of him as just
love um that makes sense you love
doesn't sleep um love doesn't love to
sleep love love loves being awake yes
and um anyway um nicole is uh i would
say equally prolific she's everywhere
and now she's here yes on the show so
let's uh hear from her let's hear from
our guest the prolific the ubiquitous
nicole byer
life could be a dream
[Music]
sorry about that hey hi hi that's really
funny
you know just keeping it silly do you
you must are you used to did you change
it for everyone has it been whoopee the
whole time it's been whoopi the whole
time my email is also whoopi goldberg
and i i changed it for a reason that i
cannot remember like eight years ago
and uh my agents just answered me faster
and uh
yes it's working out in my favor
nicole i used my manager i used to have
the same manager as um
uh jlo as jennifer lopez and so i bet
when i was starting out and um i was
obviously
much lower priority
and so but i would say i would pretend
to be like you know a sassy
assistant and i would say yes i have um
i have j lo calling
and they'd be like oh yes right away and
i get somebody immediately you know and
they'd be kind of like they've had that
like energy the frantic energy and i
said yeah it's justin i i used to love
to register the disappointment in their
voices when they were it was this jlo
justin long j.lo
very funny and i love that you did that
it's funny now nicole because now you
are a known person
uh it's go you're gonna probably have to
change that's gonna get confusing when
you you're you're gonna of course be
corresponding with other people that do
know whoopi goldberg i presume if not
whoopi herself
yeah maybe um
i don't care i don't think i'll ever
change it
it's just funny to me to have the zoom
be like whoopi goldberg's waiting to get
in and people are like whoopi
even though i know it's not you it's
like it does add a little bit of extra
pressure like you can't keep whoopi
goldberg waiting no and people usually
don't keep me waiting they respond to my
emails it's delightful
now you know how whoopi feels
you're doing okay so you're hosting so
many you have your podcast why won't you
date me i can't wait to talk about this
um
nailed it you host you're doing so much
and i didn't i didn't even realize this
all of that stuff you're doing you're
also touring at the same time i slowed
down this year
um because i was like something has to
give i feel
really overextended and a little crazy
cause the pandemic was one thing but
then 2021 everyone was like we are
vaccinated full speed ahead and i was
like wait we're going from zero to like
a thousand so it was it felt really
overwhelming and i was like i think i
need to take some time for myself and my
own mental health
so i'm not touring right now but i think
in the fall i might go back out and then
definitely next year i'm definitely
ready i just
needed a break yeah you're right nicole
there was there was also a sense because
things had slowed down i mean
lifestyle-wise um to the point where
which which in some ways and i know
everyone's probably sick of hearing
people talk about this but there was um
you know there's good and bad in that
and i found you know my own versions of
both and but um i i found part of the
good that i did find was that it um was
in slowing down i i really was able to
um
breathe and take in the world and and
enjoy life a little bit more i know i
have the luxury of doing that so i know
this sounds so privileged um truly but
um but then you're right it started up
right away and there was this sense of
like i had out i don't know that i was
after a couple of years a year and a
half
you don't feel mentally prepared to get
back into the world and again
caveat privilege i realized we are very
like
i was very thankful that i was able to
podcast from home and work from home but
yeah it was like being at home and then
like it was just like this is shooting
here you're gonna fly over here you
gotta work over here i shot my special
labor day weekend uh when i had a
three-day weekend from the show i was
shooting and this is a beautiful weirdo
yeah yeah currently on netflix yes it's
on netflix i have some questions about
you should be um thank you it's it's
really funny it's um i i i have some
questions about it because some of this
stuff is so hard for me to
believe and i love hearing other
people's experience uh no but but i i
not to suggest that it's not true but i
i had a question about um
about the white people that texted you
mm-hmm
people really did that yes
um okay you got to explain this
okay so to our mostly white audience
so the summer of 2020 when there was
tons of black lives matters protests and
we were all marching for the cause and
every company in the world was like we
care about the black people
um
white people for whatever reason or
non-black people
texted their black friends they were
like if there's anything i can do let me
know or how are you feeling or i hope
you're okay right now and it was so
interesting really really strange in a
way where i was like
do you have another black friend because
if you did and you were close to them
and you said out loud hey i'm gonna text
nicole a girl i've interacted with maybe
eight times total to see if she's okay
this summer like that black friend would
be like don't you dare don't do that
right
hopefully hopefully you should have
worked yeah you have to workshop
something like that on a true a true
friend a true black friend uh that's
funny that's really interesting what
were you what would you text back what
was the response to something like that
i think i said to a lot of people that i
was just like oh it's okay or like a
thumbs up i was
because it was just like a yellow thumbs
up yeah just like a little yellow none
[Laughter]
but it was just really interesting
because it was like okay so we're in
the midst of like one of the biggest
kind of civil rights movements that
we've seen since like the 60s which
isn't that far
back like i have aunts and stuff who
literally remember segregation so like
it's crazy and it's crazy that you only
really see color uh black and white
photos of [ __ ] when it's like this is
only like 40 50 60 years ago um i can't
do math but it was just like
just so wild for people to see what's
going on and then be like oh let me
reach out and then i just like
said it on stage to a bunch of white
people and they were like
didn't do it
uh
and then i'd find a black person in the
audience and be like i'm sorry i don't
want to single you out since you there's
only like you and me here but like did
that happen to you and every show i did
there was a black person who said yes i
think out of all the shows i did in 2021
there was maybe one who was like
that's so funny that's that's the one
person who's never interacted with
anybody
and they were in portland and i was like
all right portland keep it weird wow all
right all right that is weird yeah it's
funny that that becomes weird that
becomes an anomaly that somebody doesn't
get a text like that from well it's it's
interesting because i've been thinking
about since i saw your spot i keep
thinking about that i keep thinking
obviously from my white perspective like
what um
how i was feeling during that time and
the impulse as it's it's a wild thing
that you were getting those texts and
i'm i'm i guess proud to say i didn't
send those texts but but i but there's a
part of me and my
you know guilt and white privilege all
of that that that understands the
impulse to
want to
connect
you know and and somehow i don't
i don't i wonder what the psychological
mechanism is though that that makes
somebody
text that and what they're hoping for in
response maybe just i don't know
i don't know either i know it's like a
really hard thing to like reconcile with
like white guilt and understanding like
internalized racism and systemic racism
and then being like well what do i do
actively because honestly
actively
it's just like calling out
not okay things that some white people
say but then you don't want to be like
the pc police so it is such a really
hard thing to navigate and i get it and
it like race is just a really
interesting
hard thing to talk about and
i guess like sending a text like that
you're like well i did something right
i love that you were able to
contextualize something like that that
is kind of like
as you say a very difficult thing to
talk about very nuanced um but you you
do so uh in a very funny way i mean it's
it's through humor which is the best way
to think about things i think i yeah i
uh
it's funny because i had talked about
this thing that had happened
and my friend was just like i mean
i
they were like how do you
why talk about it and i was like well
it's kind of like therapeutic to like
make something bad that happened to you
funny and relatable to other people
and
yeah i think most comics have that in
them or they're like oh this deeply hurt
let's see how i can make it funny so it
feels better yeah i bet what shines the
light on something too so it is bringing
a positive thing to it it's like you're
talking about it in a way that is
um exposing it exposing its ugliness and
it's sometimes it's so ugly and absurd
that it it makes it funny and that's
what you do with some of these um
interactions sometimes they're just
funny and absurd sometimes they're like
you're not learning anything they like
the cat thing when you drove by the
caffeine room
uh i loved i loved that bit but people
were doing wild stuff like that during
the day yeah it was uh i think everyone
was truly just like
trying to connect in a way that we yeah
because we couldn't so it was just like
yeah me my two roommates at the time
just driving by and a honda accord with
a sign that's like sorry about your dead
cat
did did the cat owner send out an email
saying
i'm having this funeral no so a friend
of ours sent out the email to be like
okay let's do this really nice thing i
say your name in the special it's my
friend marcy and uh marcy loved that cat
dearly so like
i was i truly got the email and was like
yes
yes what a treat for marcy after her
tragic loss and then as we were doing it
i was like this is nuts
yes i know i i bet it seems like the
kind of thing where i would be
especially during the pandemic were you
like an excuse to go out yes like a
thing to do even though it's just
driving yeah driving by so it's you
you're driving by somebody's house
expressing your morning the cat how do
you mourn a cat from a how do you want a
cat in person but how do you mourn a cat
from a disease from a distance you're
just like sorry
it's funny because like i started
touring again and then i would like tell
that joke and sometimes it didn't hit as
hard and i was like oh yeah everyone in
cleveland didn't have the same pandemic
i had some people's lives
no they changed for maybe three days i
shot something in oklahoma and i was
talking to the crafty lady and i was
like did you guys have like a shutdown
she was like i mean they said we were
shut down but nobody really shut down i
was like really and she's like yeah
we've been out in these streets for a
minute it's like she's like excuse me
i even kind of and i was like oh i can't
die from oklahoma covet i can't do it no
i know every artist every stand-up has
that period where they they're going to
do it they're going to pursue their
dreams and um what what were your first
few years like when you moved to new
york you're from new jersey you grew up
in a big family right no it was just uh
me my dad my mom and my sister so it was
just four of us oh oh okay yeah i moved
to new york
right after high school
um and then like i did like i went to
this like two-year conservatory that was
[ __ ] but then i started doing ucb
stuff
and
yeah i lived in a
let's see
one two three four bedroom
apartment with one bathroom and a six
floor walk up that was definitely
illegal it was definitely a floor that
was like put on top of it and you had to
walk through my room to get to somebody
else's room and it was caving in on
itself we never locked our door we had a
massage table as our dining room table
because we didn't have any money to like
buy an actual table we found it on the
street
um the best yeah but but probably great
memories probably like happy times i
wouldn't change
or go back in time and change it at all
for anything like i had a blast i had so
much fun
and it's probably where you got a lot of
inspiration a lot of material i imagine
living you know the struggle is where
you probably found a lot yeah for the
most part yeah it was like 500 a month
like we just like wow
where was it this was um uh the upper
west side it was morningside heights so
it was like 125th in broadway and it's
changed so much now i went back
it's [ __ ] weird now because i know
city college and i think um
colombia bought buildings above 125th so
now there's like just giant [ __ ]
buildings that like block the sun and it
just it doesn't feel good anymore it
doesn't feel like neighborhoody as much
anymore yeah interesting and yet it's
probably
i mean it's it's bougie it's much more
crucial it's so much more expensive now
i paid we paid nothing
neil patrick harris lives there when
neil patrick harris moves in yeah that
means the neighborhood's gone baby yeah
yeah it's a new neighborhood
um what was the first indulgence you
allowed yourself after you had um you
know made have found success in that
world the first thing i ever bought for
myself
was at jfk i was flying back and forth
doing girl code
um
and we got picked up for a second season
and like my twitter had been blowing up
and i was like she's doing big things
also i was still nannying so like was
she um but i bought myself a purple
michael kors bag and that's the first it
was like a 200 bag
and i had been nannying and i would
bring the kids on wednesdays to the
salvation army half off day
so like that was 200 on a bag was like
nicole
nick you're bad duh i can't believe it
so yeah that was the first expensive
thing that i bought and i still have it
yeah it's funny you you adopt a kind of
like
shamey sassy there's like a
that's jim gaffigan does a version of
this you know jim gaffigan's like voice
that he uses that like
why are you two oh yeah it's kind of
like this um is is that
do you know what i'm talking about is
that deliberate are you yes okay i mean
it was like not deliberate deliberate
but uh no no no i'm sure you're not like
sometimes oh that
well it's to sell it's to like yes it's
almost like you're adopting a whole
different
person is coming out oh yeah sure but
yeah i mean it's like the internet club
being like what are you doing you're
buying a bag that's 250 dollars or
it was in your stand it's a little like
kim control and um oh yeah it's a little
like sex in the city character
kim controls my favorite character in
sex in the city i was devastated that
she did not come to do and just like
that but i
tend to believe that sex in the city of
the series is canon that's one canon
the first movie is the end of that canon
sex sexton city 2 starts a new cannon
okay and kim is in sexton city too but
sexton city 2 for me i was like this is
crazy this is these are not my
characters they're all doing things that
are crazy uh steve would never cheat on
miranda um and then i think that starts
a new canon that just like that lives in
i wish i were more familiar with both
canons i i just know that um i just i
but i do know that kim control was not
in yeah samantha samantha everything
else yeah she now lives in paris and she
doesn't really talk to carrie and it
didn't make any sense i was like
samantha is she's such a good friend she
would not just let a thing come betw i
have thought that's how they wrote her
off kind of in a way where i was like no
because i guess she got mad that like
she was a publicist for carrie and
carrie was like the book business slowed
down and i'm like she would just figure
out a different way to get you out there
so i didn't love that but they did leave
it open for her to come back but then
she's not gonna come back what's that
what's the drama behind it what's the
gossip is it that she doesn't get along
with the other actors i read somewhere
it was a money thing where it was like
for six seasons
i think sjp got to be an ep towards the
end and it's like it's an ensemble
that's funny sjp got to be an ep toward
the end
um that's fine
[Music]
wait what if you're just tuning in um
[Music]
that must sound familiar to you it's
probably not the best rendition you've
heard of it but everyone knows that
that's a beethoven masterpiece
beethoven's fur elise to be exact and
but what you may not have known is that
it was composed for the love of his life
teresa i believe it was the same love
that enabled michelangelo to sculpt the
statue of david and for da vinci to
paint the mona lisa the power of love
might be the strongest power in the
world and we can all take advantage of
the benefits it provides in incredibly
unexpected ways how the story continues
at masterworks dot art slash long that's
masterworks
dot art slash long that's masterworks
dot art slash long
i just got a nice box in the mail i was
very excited to tear into it because i
saw that it was from plus cbd i tore it
open with my teeth i am so into these
little gummies and as is our father now
they're the best the plus cbd sleep
gummies get you the rest you need to
wake up feeling focused refreshed and
ready for the day these um tasty
raspberry gummies are made with
award-winning cbd along with melatonin
magnolia bark lemon balm for powerful
sleep support plus cbd sleep gummies are
safe to use every night for better rest
here's a cool thing all plus cbd
products are third party tested and
fully traceable from seed to shelf so
you can be assured you're getting the
highest quality hemp cbd on those days
you just need a positive push plus cbd
is the perfect go-to product the pure
ingredients can help reduce stress
alleviate soreness and improve your
overall sleep um i love these things so
shop now at
pluscbdoil.com enter promo code long
l-o-n-g
for 40 off your order
[Music]
i also have to catch up i know you're a
fan of uh a certain show
i'm gonna do i want to see if you know
90 day fiance oh [ __ ] too late yeah i
[ __ ] love 90 day fiance the best yes
it's the best show on television are you
up to date
no i'm not i'm the last season was um
the zied season and uh
jay and jay was in a relationship with
the older woman who then then started
dating jay's cousin oh
yes stephanie
uh stephanie stephanie
yeah from michigan paris
i'm just gonna go into paris instead
yeah that was nuts she was boozy all the
[ __ ] i was like this lady is never
sober
um that was a good season that was a
good season i love the cold debbie
larissa
triangle or rectangle yes
wait are they still on is it still so i
think last i heard
colt and vanessa i think are getting
divorced because debbie was supposed to
move out of the house but then debbie
never moved out of the house and it's
like my dude like
you gotta let your mom go and your mom
has to let you go she's gotta cut that
cord yeah it's a real oedipus situation
going on it really is i yeah larissa was
um
you know obviously she had
her own struggles oh she's perfect
though do you follow her on instagram
her tits are so big they're so big
oh that in a newly bigger oh yeah newly
big she's so there's like a whole
niche size i want a biggie i want them
to be a biggie i love her but uh there's
a whole new section of like uh instagram
and the internet and uh called
bimbification and it's these women
who are killing
i think but she
she is she like explains it in a way
that like really makes it make sense but
she's like oh it's a sexual fetish well
i want to be a sex doll so i'm going to
pump myself full of like
silicone and i'm going to make my boobs
as big as possible my waist is tiny as
possible no i'm looking at it yeah oh no
and that's what lauren is like
of course
my big bamboo plastic news last week i
got my first ever fill of my expander
breast implants uh yeah nico why have
you done this to me i've never it's
really interesting
because it's like um
it's very like pam anderson 90s like big
titties but then they also have big
butts now
um no this is beyond this is no the face
is it looks like it looks big big big
big lips tiny noses they're like um
living bratz dolls
yes
yes this is i'm afraid oh i'm afraid to
offend anyone so i i don't i feel like i
shouldn't talk about but here's the
thing she's like so alicia's like if
you're not into it you're not into it
the people who are into it you keep
following me because that's what you
like and she's like if you don't like it
no shade i don't care yeah yeah that
makes sense but like when she's saying
to be into it i wonder what she thinks
the it is that people are the plastic
the plasticness of her though like that
she literally looks unreal oh may i mean
look hey pete there's
different strokes for yeah different
photos if the shortcut fits it fits me i
love them i like i think it's
astonishing
and like
very curious what people are willing to
do for like
for to make themselves happy like that's
it's a lot of money you have to go you
know put under anesthesia like you might
not wake up it's crazy
yeah it is i was watching a show there's
there's a great documentary named louis
theroux and uh he was on the show and uh
louis was talking about he did he did an
exposure he works for the bbc does these
documentaries the bbc and one was about
that it was about plastic surgery and
man i would watch botched and all of
those things and um
a thing that they seem to have in common
the people that they profiled they seem
to have in common was that
post-surgery
they never seemed
content like happy it never seemed to be
a
ah like a comfort in their shoes like
you know and i know it must be new it
must be shocking to see this different
but um i don't know i i i i don't want
to judge you well that's part of it
you're never done
you're never like alicia has she's i've
i i love her i've watched so many of her
videos but she uh she explained she's
like she's like i'm never done i'm a
constant work in progress i'm always
looking for the bigger the wider the
like whatever and i think she just got
she just got her nose done and she just
had like more fillers in her lips and
then she like had her chin chiseled and
she'll post before and afters and that's
my favorite because she was just like a
just like a simple white lady and now
she's this like
a blown-up plastic doll and
she's she seems genuinely so happy yeah
well hey look i mean who knows i
i don't i mean i who knows who knows
what's going on in somebody's heart i i
j i worry and this is going to sound i'm
going to sound like a karen
would a karen be worried about how that
affects uh kids looking at it like a
generation
of being exposed to somebody you stumble
upon that yeah and you see all this
positive reinforcement in the comments
like good for you you're beautiful you
know and kids
i don't know i but i don't know well i
think like
there should be all sorts of
representation in media and whatnot and
i mean i don't like i mean to like come
down on parents but like i think a
parent has to be like hey
you're okay the way you are i mean
people call me body positive and i'm
like i don't know if i'm necessarily
body i like i just like the [ __ ] fat
body i'm in i don't i don't i'm not
crying about it anymore um right i'm
also like if you don't want to be fat
you don't have to be you can take steps
to not be fat or whatever if you don't
like your nose you can go fix your nose
but also you can also just like look in
the mirror and be happy with it i'm all
for like do what makes you happy to look
in the mirror i just choose to be happy
at what i look at in the mirror and yeah
well that's great i mean if you are
positive about that i mean i i guess
it's when people say body positive i
guess they mean
it's it's putting out a good a message
to people that you you can be happy with
foreign
i'm pretty body neutral these days um
sometimes i'm more body positive than
other days yeah it changes sometimes i'm
some days i'm body negative yeah i think
same some days i look in the mirror and
i go yuck you're in new york you're
you're are you going to you're at ucb
theater like you're you're you're on
your path to doing it what would you do
when you're sitting in washington square
park just like chilling out on a nice
spring day i read a lot
so like i i read so much like one of my
favorite books was valley of the dolls
and i read that like two or three times
um i would go to
uh barnes and noble and sit on the floor
and read because i wouldn't yell at you
yeah
yeah the strand yesterday yeah the
strand
drama bookstore in the upper west side i
would sit in there and read plays
yeah i just read so much
nicole was theater what you were drawn
to i mean what what performance was what
was it that like
what was the first stage i thought i was
going to be a broadway star i really did
i yeah i thought broadway was it i
thought i was gonna do live theater
um
but then you realize
very few things are written for my type
in my age range
in plays and stuff
um a lot of the time the young engineers
is like a like a nice white lady
and
i can't sing i don't really dance so
like if i could i would be in it like i
would i probably wouldn't be a comic i'd
be in some musical touring the country
or whatever it was high school more of
like
conventional
play you know music man and stuff like
yeah we did like the last play we or
last musical we did was god spell and oh
i love god's spell yeah i have the tape
i haven't watched it but uh
at one performance i sat in someone's
father's lap as i sang turn back oh man
and
i should just watch it and be like oh
god but uh i feel like it's gonna be
very cringy um yeah i can't watch that
stuff i i have a few play in high school
i was not good i was nervous i was
uh that's tough to watch i don't think
it would i don't know how much it would
encourage me
uh yeah i feel like i gotta give up quit
it all right now
but but but like young people listening
should know that um
you know it what it i think so much of
it it comes with
uh
um experience and confidence that's how
you gain confidence you know so
certainly not uh man if you don't feel
like you have your footing right now
you're in high school you're listening
just keep doing it that's what people
say to me i'm sure you have the same
experience where people say like i wanna
how do you do it like what do you
recommend a young actor young actor and
i always say like it sounds pretentious
but like do theater do a play do theater
do a play if you don't have access to it
there's no harm in transcribing a
monologue from a movie or
something that you like where it's like
kind of chunky and recording yourself
doing it just like don't look into the
camera look off camera um and then watch
it back and then keep doing it until it
like
feels better and it feels real and then
a good idea watch the person who did it
and then watch your performance and i
think people be like well that's
cheating you're copying and it's like
you're not copying you're learning how
to be natural on camera because that's
really hard it's very hard to be natural
if you're not used to it how did you
find
uh stand up then was it through ucb was
it like
a matter of
i started doing ucb stuff and then i got
girl code which is an mtv show and then
colleges colleges have these like
budgets to like fly comics out for their
like orientations or
homecoming things so they were like we
all love girl coach so we want girl code
and guy code comedians to come to our
schools and i said to my manager at the
time i was like i could do like a sketch
i could bring my wigs and he was like no
learn how to do stand-up and i was like
okay
he was like just take your characters
and like because i did sketches and
stuff and he was like just turn that
into premises oh that that's interesting
that makes sense nicole because maybe
that's where a lot of the voices come
from oh yeah
yeah oh okay that's funny did you have
confidence when you were on stage i mean
to me that always i just passed by uh
every time i see a stand up i think god
i i'm nervous for them you know i think
it takes such balls to do that at first
i mean and lady balls
all the balls um i went to dinner with
my friend emily heller last night who's
uh she's a comic and she's a writer and
she's
incredibly funny she was at my first
show is rutgers university and i was
like emily you should close you're an
actual comic you've been doing this for
like years to my this is my first show
where i'm doing more than 10 minutes and
she was like no you're on tv they're
here to see you i was like okay and i
got on stage and i was up there for like
35 40 minutes and i was like huh they're
laughing at [ __ ] that's not funny and i
was like oh
it's because i'm on tv and it's because
they already like me so then i was like
okay i can coast in these college shows
so now i have to come back to la and see
if that material works for people who
don't know who i am so i kind of worked
backwards from because usually you'll do
material it doesn't work and you try to
figure it out you workshop it yeah i
would do material that i knew was kind
of not funny
but like would get a laugh because they
knew me and then bring it to la and do
shows every night of the week and try to
work it for people who didn't know me so
then yeah it was
weird because i knew i had a like a a
finite time to get good
yes
people forget about you but they still
book you on shows you have to be funny
you can't not be funny so i was like i'm
gonna figure out how to how i'm funny as
a stand-up
uh and it took a minute but i think i
got there
oh that's interesting oh yeah but yeah
you have netflix questions i i mean um i
wanna talk about why won't you date me
because it's it's such a huge hit and um
and it's and the premise is so
interesting because it's it's all based
on you
not having a love in in your life you're
not having a partner which is such a
great premise it's such a such an
interesting thing to to explore but um
what happens when you do find
love do you have to end it i don't think
i'll end it um
i think
i don't know i think that's like just
like another chapter in my life where
i'm like what is it like dating somebody
and it's like why won't you jamie
because i already got somebody sorry
about it
but then you could call it uh why will
you date me yeah why will you date me
because somebody why are you dating me
yeah yes
why have you decided
um what what do you find is the most
common link i mean in terms of
uh not being dateable because i i went
through god the dating world was
something that uh i had a very hard time
navigating and yeah i'm happy i'm not in
it
yeah it sucks um a lot of people are
like you know just like met some great
people you should say great people
really i've only met trash no i'm
kidding i've also met some really great
people um
i guess
people always they're like you know
don't be so much and then the longer
i've done it the more i'm like oh don't
dim myself for anybody like if
somebody's going to date me and want to
be with me they're going to want to be
with all of me
they're going to like everything about
me or not everything but like for the
most part they're going to like that i'm
loud they're going to like that i'm
assertive they're going to like that i
like to laugh and
not and like be okay with being the loud
table at dinner or whatever
nico i can't believe you haven't found
somebody like that i only because like
you seem like such a social but you seem
like such a gregarious charming person
i'm surprised that
you haven't found that there's been a
lot of studies that uh men do not want
to date funny women
oh for real
uh-huh that men are just like genuinely
not attracted to funny women um oh man i
i
not well not this man
i i love funny but funny is like ver you
know that's the top of the list for me
i wonder why
i don't know i am
i mean i have i can't i have so many
tabs open on my computer but i have one
window of a like eight tabs open because
i've been researched i'm not researching
but i was like genuinely curious about
it i was like i keep finding studies
that say
that men are just not attracted to funny
women but like it's not to say all of
them
um yeah i don't know i don't know what
it is maybe it's like the men think like
i don't know maybe there's some kind of
inherent sexist
uh traditional thing like men are
supposed to be the ones who are funny
because they are the ones who are
having to court the women they're having
to do the maybe
maybe i don't know and also like i know
i'm specific i'm fat i'm black
i'm pretty independent like i know all
of that is that's like a whole package
that you have to be like okay unwrapping
um i'm because sometimes i'll be like oh
it's because mandeling funny women and
people be like you're all so fat i'm
like yeah i know but like your mom
probably is too and she probably still
[ __ ] your dad so like that's the let's
take that as an equation um
yeah it's just it's a lot it's a i know
that i'm a a lot of things
that
aren't traditionally seen as like
appealing or attractive
and that's not me being down on myself
that's me no no no no no i i yeah i see
the people out in the world who
are in like you know monogamous relation
or not monogamous uh what is it they're
like serial serial people who are always
in a relationship serial monogamy yes
is there a physical type that you are
attracted to i mean do you you type i
mean it is true that there's a
superficiality to dating um there's a
there's a reality to that but is there a
certain
you know physicality that you look for
the last couple of guys i've gone out
with have been real nerds they're just
real nerdy looking um
i don't think i have nothing wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with that
listeners
oh we have a type i think um
i mean honestly right now i'm just
looking for someone who's nice i think
that's a night like who's nice kind
treats me well
yeah
yeah good well i'm rooting for you
because you seem like a really really
nice person yourself so thank you life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hey parents this one's for you
wondering's kids and family podcast
little stories everywhere transports
your family to an imaginative world with
enchanting stories and exciting
adventures in each episode hosts
virginia madsen and robbie damond read
an original children's tale if you've
been looking for screen free
entertainment for your kids little
stories everywhere encourages your
little ones to use their imaginations in
one of their latest tales you'll hear
about mark the unicorn he's just like
any other unicorn except he doesn't have
a horn that makes him an easy target for
school bullies
that is
until he runs into the most popular
unicorn in school sprinkles and their
unexpected adventure changes his life
forever listen to little stories
everywhere on amazon music apple
podcasts or listen early and ad free by
joining wandery plus kids in apple
podcasts or wondering plus in the
wondery app
[Music]
and big beautiful weirdo why do you call
yourself a weirdo because that's in the
title of the stand up um
i know i'm a little weird if if aliens
came to town to
the plan and you you were to describe
yourself to them and you said i'm a
little weird and they were like why are
you weird uh what what would how would
you
articulate that um
i'm just like really authentically me
like i went to
a restaurant with my friend sashir who i
keep talking it's like i don't have any
other friends
uh okay
three myself
and my other friend christy we were in
india okay there's a new friend another
friend christy cello i [ __ ] love her
and we were at a restaurant and we all
we ordered our food our food was coming
and
they were telling us what we were you
know they're like who has the whatever
and one of the servers was holding big
silverware and i snatched it i went look
at the big silverware and then i started
crying
because i just loved the big silverware
so much um just things like that like
people are crying over silverware but i
you were weeping over how
you like the that is okay i understand
things that are big that aren't supposed
to be and i love things that are small
that aren't supposed to be i i i i agree
with you i'm the same i
nico i just bought a smart car okay i
used smart car
uh so i you were you were preaching to
the choir i love
i love going by like i love taking road
trips and seeing like you know the
biggest ball of twine and like the
biggest horseshoe if there's uh one day
you know i i really want to do a full-on
i have this camper van i want to take it
around and find the wildest
big little oddities
that sounds like a true treat i love it
i went to south carolina
and
my friend's dad lived there and she was
like go hang out with my dad and i was
like okay cool
i don't care and then i was like hey do
you want to take me to the world's
biggest fire hydrant and he was like
okay
yes you know why i'm so happy about it i
was like
i was so happy and i was like for the
whole day
oh that's great and great instagram
content it's good gram content but it's
all right
i'll just like look at it and be like a
big fire hydrant look how tiny i am i
know i love stuff like that no i know um
all right we have a lightning round uh
it's so fun to talk to you i i don't
want it to end but there's a quick quick
lightning round okay
okay um what is your favorite emoji
your go-to um the go-to one that i use
is that purple heart or that lady whose
hands are up like that he's like i don't
know
i don't know yeah use that a lot um
often uncertain of things i guess uh who
was your first celebrity crush vin
diesel
oh wow you had that i so read it cut out
pictures of vin diesel and made a vin
diesel
my collage i loved him
oh god wow oh i love i still love vin
diesel
what was what
what was the thing i mean when do you
remember the moment of
it was definitely fast and the furious i
love that movie i think it's
incredibly well done
um and then i loved him and michelle
rodriguez there's this one scene where
they're like
dirty from fixing up a car and she like
straddles him and it's like the only
sexual part of the whole franchise um
that's the furious part it was a very
furious part
uh yeah i was like
he does it for me
yeah oh yeah there's a great family
i love
you that's a good one do you do a
celebrity impressions
um i do a bad one of
uh emma stone
oh yes uh let's see
emma let me ask emma i'll ask i'm gonna
ask emma this um emma because it'd be
great to get her on the podcast um i'm
so glad we have her for one question
uh emma what is your favorite ice cream
flavor so okay so my favorite ice cream
flavor i guess i would have to say is
pralines
that's you know what i'm closing my eyes
i can
sort of she does have kind of which is
such a charming aspect of her person she
does have a slight there's a goofiness
to her it's goofy and it's raspy so it's
like raspy kind of like
yeah yeah there's a um yeah yeah there's
just like a little bit of a list going
on yes yes yes
yeah it's not a great impression but i
hope she's not listening to this because
i think she is one of the nicest
funniest uh
and this so this
two people going like this about you
like this is what she's i hope that's
not oh i don't mean any disrespect i
like her a lot i uh
ran into her i had a general at this uh
a general is a meeting that you have
with producers and they're nice to you
and they don't give you a job but i had
a general
that is
so well said yes
they're like we just want to get to know
you you're like yes i'm like i don't
need another friend and i know you don't
really care about my life yes
but good meals good meals yeah yeah very
nice meals and i
i was at the like their offices and as i
was leaving emma stone was there and i
just she like held the door for me and i
was like thank you and then i went to
the bathroom i was like you did it you
were very cool like you were normal yeah
you behaved normally she doesn't people
are probably not normal to her at all
but i want to be like what are you doing
here emma stone
is not funny
that's a good instinct nicole i man i
hope she's listening for many reasons
famous people are very funny i went to
snl once and jonah hill was also going
and we were going into 30 rock and he
was standing in front of me and i felt
my arms raise up and i was like what's
happening i was like oh i think i'm
trying to hug jonah hill and i was like
oh i don't know him he doesn't know me
but it felt like i knew him and
that's funny well he's also a very
huggable guy i get that just
he's just such a nice friendly face
he's
yes you would i'm you know what he's one
of the few people you probably could
have at first he probably would have
been like whoa whoa dude what are you
doing but um yeah if he if he knew that
you were friendly and safe uh he's a
he's a hell of a hugger he's a good man
um
what is your what is an acclaimed movie
that you're embarrassed to admit you
haven't seen like people trying to shame
you for
i've never seen any of the indiana
joneses i've never seen the godfathers
oh [ __ ] i'm here name some movies that
you love
jaws you never seen like the future what
never seen jaws name some more movies
right back to the future i've seen back
to the future i've seen all of you okay
planes trains and automobiles yeah
the jerk no
young frankenstein no
oh nicole i i hope you're not writing
these down you should be writing these
down um you have such great
entertainment an idea um watch jaws
watch the godfather um
uh but you know that that's why you
answered the question that way you know
that you claimed yeah there's ten like
honestly name three more i bet you
haven't seen them oh oh my god oh wow um
tootsie no oh wait no i just watched
tootsie that's a lie okay
yes oh so good um just trying to think
of my favorites um
never ending story
the neverending story these are 80s i
mean i'm going to try though the luck
dragon or something yes
okay what is a game show you host uh
nailed it you host so many things um
wipe out wipe out what is a game show
that you would like to be a contestant
on
okay i've i've been a contestant on
family feud
oh but i love family feud me too
one of my favorite comics he's so funny
he can really just make anything funny i
love him
yes me too
um yeah were you nervous when you were
on because i there was i i was i found
myself like really sweating yeah i did
fast money and
wow me too spoiler he said when i say
cheese you say and i went big and he was
like what
because i was like big cheese in charge
but they were looking for like cheddar
swiss oh sure
yeah i don't want to shame you any more
than you probably have been shamed for
that answer but
yes that's enough very very
very bad the big spoon thing i'm on
board for the big spoon thing i don't
find weird but yes big in response to
cheese is um
that's weird um yeah
uh oh man he must have been he must have
loved you um uh if you could learn
another language what would it be
spanish
oh yeah i speak spanish a little bit i
tried again but
you speak spanish um
i i wish i'd kept with it after high
school too
um and duolingo what a [ __ ] so annoying
i
know i know people are sick of hearing
me talk about on the show but i'm with
you nicole uh
do you drink coffee or tea and how do
you take it coffee black
great
solid um what is your favorite cereal my
favorite cereal i think is cinnamon
toast crunch yes
the best
and then there's these other ones
there's like these o's i can't remember
what those are called crackling oh um
yes yeah i love those me too me too and
who else does god this was such a yes
somebody else on the show recently
um oh oh alicia silverstone oh that
makes me so happy
right i just like to connect because if
you ever hold the door for her or she
holds the door for you
craig i know yes um
what is um if you had to choose a
different first name we talked about
this uh instead of nicole what would it
be okay
so my my middle name is michelle and my
mother at one point said
do you want to go buy shelly and i was
like no ew shelly but i now i'm like
shelly buyer that's kind of fun
there's there aren't any i don't know
anyone named shelly who's my age
no shelley's kind of like a a nice
old-fashioned name you don't meet a lot
of young you don't need a lot of babies
names
and i kind of wish i had gone with it
and then
and a nice connection to your mom that
would be cool shelly okay um that's a
great answer if you had a sandwich named
after you the nicole beyer sandwich what
would what would be on it what would it
be bacon lettuce tomato grilled chicken
and kraft ranch dressing with a little
bit of salt and pepper
yes what bread is it on i think it's on
like a toasted
baguette but it has to it can't be too
crunchy on the outside just enough and
then very soft on the inside
yes god i love this place bay cities in
santa monica if you ever if you're ever
there the best sandwich place um but
yeah the crunchy on the outside bread
can really
hurt the teeth well when i heard the
gums what am
what is your favorite tom hanks movie oh
forrest gump it's i love forrest gump
yeah i will watch forrest gump anytime
it comes on television
um one of those movies that you may have
been shamed for not seeing uh if you
haven't seen it big you should watch
never seem big okay you got a lot of
great ones ahead of you um would you
rather take a time machine to the past
or the future future gotta see if i'm
married baby
yeah oh yes okay
i can't wait to hear what the name of
the podcast is gonna be called then um
are you more of a talker or a texter
text her until i'm like ugh i'm tired
yes i know takes forever um night or
morning person night
do you prefer the toilet roll over or
under
under
yes oh under yeah because it's easier to
like rip it off
okay i disagree but many people agree
with you um finish this it's okay you're
the guest i don't have to agree um
finish the sentence if you would nicole
this is our final thing um life is short
so
make yourself happy but don't make
people
make yourself happy but don't hurt
people in the process
i love it yes very true sage
um and you seem like a person that that
uh is is very good at doing that um
yeah uh you make a lot of people happy
and you made me so happy thank you this
was fun i had a nice time i know how
busy you are so thanks for taking the
time yeah thank you for having me what a
treat
[Music]
so that has just happened
yes it's like a oh it's what is that
it's like a playful playful but also
slightly suggestive alter ego she has a
great laugh she has a very
yeah yeah like a little thing like
giggle yeah it doesn't sound like
samantha is it samantha from sex in the
city she's yeah kim catrell kim control
she's a huge fan huge of sex in the city
you could not keep up with her oh well i
know very little at all you were like i
just know that she wasn't in it i just
know her voice that's the reason i
brought it up she loves it she loves
that 90 day fiance which is so fun to
talk about you could relate to her about
that i went down a wormhole after i
heard you guys talking about larissa or
clarissa yes
i got this message from cecily strong oh
speaking of 90 day fiance and she played
this she sent me these clips that i it
makes me want to see the new season so
badly oh smarted yes it premiered yeah
have you seen the new season no i can
understand why people
are fascinated by these relationships
because they're so clearly the dynamic
that they're so clearly um
you know what it is it's purely
transactional but there's a really funny
part uh it says i hadn't seen this i
guess that swallow was on another season
of it oh i heard a swallow um they might
be heading for divorce well that's not
that's a huge shocker but i
i i'd be interesting to see how that
went down but she said please please
please tell me you watched us swallow in
a santa hat with straggly long gray hair
tackling his sister at christmas
i mean they're just that alone i have to
how what what kind of a tease kalani
no i just want you to be nice
speaking up should i pick this up
okay let's give it a shot
hey mom hi hon i have a slight conundrum
uh-oh
uh just a podcast oh
okay that's all right what's what do you
what's your conundrum
um
i i printed out the the recipes for you
for the
maybe i will have you make those but i
want you to come and get i bought the
buttermilk i got the
little cupcake filler you know
okay
and um
also there was one other thing oh yeah
the potatoes here's my conundrum the
potatoes have to cook at 350
an hour after you go through all this
other stuff that is a conundrum
for the lamb oh why didn't i cook them
so i got an oven christmas got an oven i
got two ovens what yeah whoa
lucky
oh honey he's joking nobody has two uh
get a car
in a car um yeah probably just transport
them in an automobile
i know
they would just maybe just warm up we
could just kind of stick them in the
oven to warm them up i don't think it's
qualified as a condenser yeah no all
right well listen let me call you
afterwards and i can cook him or
christian can it's not that easy stop
the conundrum solved
oh okay all right well we'll we'll be in
church and about we're leaving around
20 to seven but you're not talking about
cooking the
potatoes tonight oh no no no this is for
sunday oh okay so
i'll come over when we're done
okay that sounds good okay all right
love you okay bye
our mother's been having trouble
sleeping at night yeah she's been waking
up early in the morning and um with her
mind racing yeah and i can see why you
got a little glimpse you got a little
taste another glimpse of it
um by the way i have to say about
cooking potatoes three days from now
today's thursday and she's talking about
a dinner on sunday not only talking
about it like anxious about it yeah well
thanks caliper and cd plus c cb ct yeah
cbt it by the way if she if this works
for her oh she should become the spokes
spokeswoman yes yeah i'm excited she
could be like where's the beef lady
she'd be like where's the weed yeah
where's the problem
um yeah i'm excited for uh our father i
i think because back in the day he was
probably he was like a cool philosophy
guy he was like um in his 60s
when so he definitely what if we go over
later he's like listening to the
grateful dead he's wearing like tie-dye
shirts yeah
he's like what's up yuppies
um
yeah that was what do you think i'm
curious if you think that call is going
to get left in the show i hope so yeah
me too it's it might be my favorite part
of the episode so far
i wonder what nicole was not including
the interview of course of course of
course i love how you asked her the
question about what movie um she might
get shamed for oh yeah and she and she
like hadn't seen any movies and then you
like but then but you were so
incredulous about all of them i tried to
shave yeah but but it didn't work no
she's like shame proof yes you were like
you haven't seen that and she was like
no no yep sorry try again yeah she's
like name more she's kind of bragged
yeah she i haven't seen jaws i haven't
seen gone with the wind i mean the list
goes on but i haven't seen gone with the
wind either oh really it's um long right
it's long and i imagine windy
imagine it's quite
uh problematic yes and someone leaves at
the end
and they they go yeah and it's kind of
like
leaves are going everywhere and yeah
they just kind of get blown away
yeah you you get it i get it you don't
have to see it um scarlett o'hara yeah
yeah yada yada yada you guys are looking
out no that's uh casablanca um
which i you know i've never seen uh
maltese falcon i haven't either i've
never seen citizen kane oh i've i've
seen that oh we did so funny we talked
about that
i talked about uh that with guy pierce
oh spoiler alert oh maybe not maybe i
just spoke to him socially okay how do
you know for the podcast i don't
that'd be a cool friend guy yeah yeah
cool guy to know speaking of guys um i
if if you're ever in new orleans there
is a great bar called one eye jacks um
our dear friend rio owned it he he
passed away and uh we just want to say
to his family and his friends we
we loved rio so much rio hackford he was
one of the one of the greats one of the
originals and so uh if you are in new
orleans my favorite bar there uh by far
is a place called one eye jax maybe your
favorite bar in the country in the
country yes i would say that's true and
he rio made a thing called a guy and so
um it was a dream remember that we'd
have you guys oh my god yeah what a fun
person what a great guy and uh a fun
drink to have in his honor so if you're
down there uh sidle up and and get a guy
in in rio's honor so we we loved him and
to his family we are you're in our our
prayers
anyway sorry for that
yes any who but but
very important worth saying yeah um you
bought a smart car oh yes a little bit
more news more justin news that i
learned from listening to a podcast
so i can't believe i didn't tell you
that no i was in that you know i have
kobit too right i know that from
listening to the podcast oh really now
you talked about it all right um
and so i got a smart car i had been
wanting one for years
i always thought they were i have a
fantasy of like you know just being able
to park anywhere in the city
and um in new york and um
i love it you know what's funny about it
is like the looks that you get is uh and
you you can't look cool which i kind of
like about it there's no way to
you know we talking about being younger
and like blasting music they're
ridiculous-looking
my friend liz had one they're ridiculous
i really like them i talked to chelsea
handler made fun of me for it on her
part everyone's going to make fun of you
yeah yeah i kind of i don't mind that
should we read a letter let's read a
letter here all right well this is a
long one
you see this yeah i'm looking at it okay
from chris graves subject turtles
watches and monopoly hi brothers long
i hope this missive finds you well my
name is chris pronounced chris with a
silent h sound
and if this was a phone call you might
find yourself saying oh you're a woman
i get that a lot with a name like chris
spelled without a k
and then uh an old-fashioned tongue-out
face the old i haven't seen that in a
long time so p yeah it's a colon with a
dash and an uppercase p oh that's funny
i haven't seen them in a long time
anywho
anywho chris says i'm a long time
listener it sounds like it thank you
both for the joy you bring to my daily
walks oh thank you chris this is so nice
um
so recently justin you've had a couple
anecdotes that had me saying me too or
ha do i have a monopoly story for you
first my me too story and then an
old-fashioned winky face
i too do not wear watches somewhere in
my 20s i discovered my dislike for
watching time too much before that i'll
admit my teens were filled with
collecting an assortment of cool swatch
watches
yes i've clearly dated myself weren't
the 80s wonderful they were oh man but
like i said earlier by my 20s i stopped
wearing watches a habit i maintained to
this day i'm the youngest of six kids
and for a solid eight years my brother
john would give me a watch for christmas
which yes is super nice but also says a
little something about his powers of
observation that's true i finally had to
pull him aside one year and let him
gently down me
john i love you so much and this is a
lovely watch but the thing is i don't
wear watches john
oh
i thought you just kept losing the ones
i gave you
it's funny brothers you gotta love them
second my monopoly story as i mentioned
above i'm the youngest of six when i was
but a freshly minted baby my dad was
playing a rousing game of monopoly with
my siblings it was 1970 and my father
was a pretty successful businessman so
when my sister leslie was 13 at the time
won the game beating my four brothers
and my father well my dad was not happy
and in fine sore loser mode he pitched a
fit and flipped the board over hey yeah
i can relate i never got to play
monopoly with my father because he chose
to never play monopoly with us kids
again
wow
his loss in another old-fashioned
tongue-out phase thirdly i happen to
produce a lot of documentary television
cool and back in november of 2014 i was
on a show filming on mona island in
puerto rico this island is uninhabited
wow that's cool and a nature reserve so
we had to pitch tents on a beach for the
two weeks we were staying and shooting
there
that is man that is a dream the island
also happens to be a hatching site for
sea turtles oh boy here we go did you
just perk up justin yeah i sure did i
can testify
but due to climate change we had heard
that the beach hadn't been used by the
turtles for a couple years so you can
imagine our surprise one night when we
when we were woken up in the middle of
the night because turtle legs were
hatching
oh wow that sound i i can imagine it's
just like the crinkling of like little
things like jurassic park yeah but i i
i also know that sound of when i was in
nicaragua i was at a turtle sanctuary
and they
they were one day old hatchlings and the
sound of them all moving together is
like something i'll never forget the
full moon was out and the beach was
covered with tiny baby turtles
they were so cute and the moment was
filled with so much awe
we helped guide the little ones to the
water for their first swim it is truly
one of the most amazing things i've ever
witnessed and knowing your love of
turtles justin i thought i'd share this
story with you thank you chris for doing
that yes i i imagining it being amazing
lastly would you rather okay would you
rather get to only play male mostly
one-dimensional leads in one genre of
film for your whole career i.e action
star rom-com star et cetera but also be
beloved by audiences or or
only get to be small supporting roles
for your whole career with no limit to
the kinds of characters you can be but
no one will ever recognize you for your
work we've had a version of this the
first one definitely
you know we've had this like a version
of this and it's a good question chris
um
i would say the second one for sure
but but again like we said last time
only because i've
i have some experience now with um
being known for acting work and and
knowing what what comes with that and
the good and bad but it's not worth it
it's not worth the
the lack of diversity in getting to act
here's my devil's advocate point
uh if you choose a
the one where you're celebrated and
you're in these big movies
that means that even though you have to
play one-dimensional characters
uh it means that you those movies have
brought pleasure
to so many people that's true so if you
don't if you step outside
of the question like your own desires of
like either wanting to be like a cool
indeed for the world it's better for the
world not better for the world
necessarily but more net possible you're
bringing more
potentially you're bringing more
happiness to people anyway but great
question chris and uh back to chris she
says yay you've reached the end of this
letter love you both make it a
spectacular day boys chris wow well
great letter yeah you really helped make
it a spectacular day thanks chris and um
thank you everyone who's listening
thanks to nicole man yeah that was um
that was quite that was a that was fun
that was a nice talk and uh and and nice
for her to take the time because she's
the most she's the busiest person in
show business now you should try to get
on her podcast how do i do that i don't
know
okay reach out uh oh you know what we
texted it because i had apologized about
missing our first see that'd be fun to
be out there that would be fun again
amazing she's just that she has time to
do all this i don't know how she does it
i know she is um she is a worker she
works hard and um and thank you for so
thanks to her for taking the time and
and for all of you for listening uh and
chris for that nice letter sorry
and if you guys would like to write in
like chris did which you said in the
beginning no but i'm going to bookend
here wow okay life is short at
wondery.com
and we'll talk to you all next week
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian lawn also produced by megan
the monaco and katy
allen senior producers michelle miesha
lans and the audio engineer is a sergio
henry
and a man who occasionally goes out to a
nice dinner marshall louie he's also the
executive producer of life ashore oh yes
and we do it all for a company called
one day
[Music]
will you stop my
excitement
just the thought of it
and she continues remind me never to
have sushi here again
speaking of did you see that documentary
my octopus teacher oh
you saw it
oh so beautiful does it make you ever
want to eat octopus again
yeah it looks good a cute little thing i
didn't see you oh you did no i want to
oh
why didn't you want to eat octopus more
no not if they're like real such
sentient sentient maybe you won't know
you won't have a personal attachment i
know at this point i always thought they
were so big they're not that big
no you're thinking of like captain ahab
and like the giant squib maybe yeah
squid you think of like a crap
they have giant squid
you have the kraken
you should know it's so beautiful that
movie if you like our show please give
us a five star rating and a review and
be sure to tell your friends the next
episode will be out in a week but you
can listen to it right now ad free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app you can follow this show on amazon
music apple podcast and the wondery app
or wherever you're listening right now
in the episode notes you'll find some
links and offers from our sponsors
please support them another way you can
show support for the show is by filling
out a survey at wundery.com
survey so thank you for supporting
you